Hello, everyone.
This is a DPR lecture
on adolescent
wellness. I am once
again, Dr. Thomas
Chan, and here's
my email if you
need to contact me.
These are the
session objectives,
pretty straightforward.
You'll see by
the end of the
talk what I think
is important.
All right. So let's
go. So adolescent care.
Basically, these
are the ages of
when you think of
adolescence. Okay.
The meat of it is
really like, I would say
13 to 18, like the
teens. But, you know,
the allies, 11 to 12,
some things do happen
during that younger
period that we should
keep a close eye on.
But luckily, most of
the time, everything's
okay. And of course,
at 18, teenagers are
still far from being
fully developed, right?
Right. So, you know,
we extended to 21
and depending on the
pediatrician, we'll
talk at the end of the
talk about when we
transition to adulthood.
Everyone's a little
different. You know,
I personally, I keep
kids up to like 23,
24, 25 until they
don't want to keep me,
keep me most of the
time. And they're ready
for an adult doctor
and others don't ever
want to leave. And
I'm like, all right,
it's enough now.
You have to go to an
adult doctor. All
right, so we'll see.
All right, so the biggest
thing is adolescents,
they're transitioning
from being a child
and being completely
dependent on the
parents, and they, you
know, realize like, hey,
I'm growing up, and
they're struggling
for independence, which
is extremely normal.
but the thing is that
the brain is still kind
of developing and the
world is getting is
a scary place and it
could lead to definitely
lead to high-risk
behavior so you have
to be aware of that all
right just understanding
when you're taking
care of adolescents
there's definitely
traditional care right so
you still have to
take care of all their
usual stuff you know
sprained ankles broken
bones sore throats
headaches so you're still
doing all that stuff
that you know how to
do as a doctor uh you
understand but in the
back of mind you understand
they're undergoing
a transition right
so it's a change and
you have to be aware of
that okay you're always
you're a treasure
hunter looking for
issues that couldn't be
a problem you're trying
to always anticipate
what what's coming
next all right um so and
it's not always evident
uh so you most
teenagers are also very
very reserved that
way too right they're
starting they're starting
to be not trusting of
of certain people of
the world of the man
or whatever so you know
you have to try to uh
to see if you can find
the problems if they
exist all right
understand about there's
certain more pressing
problems uh especially
during adolescence and
you need to take the
time all right so this
is not one of those
that uh you can get
in and out and see a
teenager four well child
in five ten minutes
it just if you're doing
it you're just not
doing it right all
right So, you know, it's
very common when I see
teenagers on my schedule,
I know in my mind,
even though the
schedule for a 30 minute
block, I'd be very,
very lucky if I, if I'm
finishing 30 minutes.
Most times it takes
45 hour. And if
there's a real big
problem, it can take
longer. And you just
have to accept that.
all right so looking
at 2014 statistics
from the cdc you
can see by and large
unintentional injury
in the young adulthood
is the biggest thing
okay then suicide
number two all right
and then homicide
especially during the
high risk ages you
know 15 to 24 and uh you
know uh young adulthood
all right adults,
but the young adults.
Otherwise, cancers,
congenital problems,
especially, you know,
like maybe heart problems
or genetic issues,
heart disease as
well. Okay, so those,
you know, are still
present, but lower down
than things like, you
know, unintentional
injury, suicide, and
homicide. Okay, if you
look at 2021 CDC stats,
I couldn't get to
find anything
closer, you still see
unintentional injury
number one okay uh suicide
and homicide is probably
two and three once
again when you're
young some cancers uh
go get in there and
since this is 2021 this
covid time you can
see covid did cause um
some mortality in
young adults right it's
it didn't affect uh
young people as much
as as elderly but um
but it definitely had
an effect and you can
see it in the stats,
right? So when we talk
about unintentional
injury, look at
the stats from the
CDC. What are we
talking about? Most of
the time, 73% is motor
vehicle accidents,
right? Either
they're driving, they
were in the car with
someone else driving,
or, you know, they
got hit by a car,
okay?
Poisonings,
drownings, of course,
discharge from firearms.
So there are other
things, but by and
large driving okay and
that's what starts
happening when they're
teenagers right so
understanding the adolescent
the stages of
adolescence right so i
think you got this during
your adhd adolescent
adolescent adolescent
lecture um so basically
early you think of
you know early you
know middle school age
right puberty is just
starting they're just
starting to struggle
for independence,
but they're still
very, very childish
in a lot of ways.
And they look,
they still look
like children most
of the time, okay?
They're hanging out.
The boys are hanging
out with the boys.
Girls are hanging out
with the girls.
They might intermingle
a little bit, but
not that much, right?
That's the middle
school dance where
everyone's still, all
the boys on one side
of the gym, girls
on one side of the
gym, right? I don't
know if they still
have dances like that.
But they're
starting to be
interested in ***, right?
So, But they're really
concrete thinkers,
and this is the main
thing that when you're
young, you're thinking
very concretely,
like black and white,
right and wrong, okay?
Middle is that
transition time, right?
You're thinking early
high school, early to
mid high school, so
continued physical
changes, right? So you
see the freshmen, they
look kind of like
kids. By the time
they're juniors, they
look like adults, okay?
More independence,
highest family conflict.
So when do kids
have the most conflict
is in high school
with the family, right?
Because in middle
school, they're arguing
also, but they're
still very childish.
So parents can still
control them. They still
have a lot of control
over them if they
want to try to exert
that. But in high
school, it's much, much
harder, right? Kids
can drive on their own.
They don't need you
to provide them food.
They can find somewhere
else to stay if
you kick them out
of the house, right?
It's not optimal,
but that's the truth,
right? So parents
are losing control,
and a lot of times
they don't like
it, and the kids
are becoming more
independent, but they're
not ready for it.
And the mixed peer
groups, both male and
females are mixing, and
the maturing thought
process. And the
late are, you know,
just think probably,
you know, half of you
guys are just, you
know, at the tail end
of that late adolescence,
much more mature
self-identity,
thinking, independent,
mature relationships,
can think about the
future, like I want to
be a doctor, you know,
and they can think of
things in gray. oh
yeah, I didn't like
that, but I can see why
they thought like that,
right? So you can see
that versus in middle
school, they're just
like, I just didn't
like that, right? So
there's a difference,
all right? And
you can see, you
know, these mature
relationships, you
know, that, you
know, high school
sweethearts,
college definitely,
you know, a relationship
college a lot of
times can last into,
you know, a marriage and
throughout their lives,
right? Because they're
much mature in that
way okay adolescents
again distinct very
very moody you just got
to accept that sometimes
they are concrete
thinkers sometimes they're
they can be a little
bit more expansive
but a lot of times
they're a concrete
thinker they're starting
about sexuality and love
uh ***** at the same
time they're going to
do this is they're going
to do the pupital
changes which kind of
goes hand in hand their
physical changes and
the cognitive changes
peers peer groups become
very very important
sometimes you ask a
lot of teenagers it
becomes more important with
than what the parents
and loved ones say
all right so uh so the
the peer groups have
extreme influence on
on on kids on these
adolescents all right so
you really want to build
rapport from minute
one that you enter the
room uh because that's
really gonna help
you throughout the the
process in terms of you
know them listening
to what you you want
from them your guidance
that you want to impart
upon them and yeah
that's that's really
it I mean rapport
building with patients is
always important but
teenagers are especially
it's a very stressful
time during and they're
stressily confused
and they're very very
wary of any authority
figure a lot of times
and you know being a
physician is an authority
figure you know and
even if they loved you
throughout their whole
childhood you see
when they're teenagers
they just like whereas
they used to give you
a hug when they were
like you know seven
eight years old um now
they're like like i'm
i'm a grown-up and stuff
like that all right
uh so i always like to
make introductions and
i personally try to
you know build the
rapport with the teenager
first right i want
them to feel that they
are that they're not
just the kid uh that
they're an independent
adult. So, you know, a
lot of times when I go
in to see a teenager,
I'll go straight to
them, make eye contact,
shake their hand,
address them first, and
then I'll address the
parents. All right. So,
so John, Jane, how are
you? And hi, Mr. Jones.
What's going on? Nice
seeing you
again. All right.
You know, building
rapport, just asking if
there's any, any concerns
going on you know
a little chit chat
in there you know
what's going on why are
you here oh you need
a form filled out okay
you know oh what do
you what's you know
sport you need clearance
for oh softball got
it okay uh whatever
are there any problems
oh i have a headache
my neck's been hurting
whatever okay so
uh i always say no
confidential questions
yet so why is your chit
chat and uh even if
parents want to talk
about *** oh i i think
i think he's you know
having *** i'm like
all right all right
we'll definitely
address it later okay
what what happens that
you don't want to
address something that um
it's going to make
the teenager in an
awkward position because
he or she may not want
to tell you the
truth in front of the
parents right so they're
more likely to lie
and later on when you
get them alone they're
more likely to
perpetuate that lie So I
always, if, if there
is like a really, um,
you know,
you know, intense
question that I think he
or she's depressed or
I think he or she's
having ***, things like
that. I'm like, all
right, all right. But
what makes you think
that Ms. Jones, you
know, you just get some
history and say, all
right, well, we're going
to talk about it. I'm
going to, you know,
um, talk about it
later and, uh, we'll
definitely address some
of these concerns. Okay.
Uh,
some doctors do the
physical exam with
the parents there
and some, um, um,
pediatricians do
the exam without,
without the parents.
Okay. I like to kind
of, most of the time
I like to do like
a cursory, my usual
screening, physical
exam with the parents
in there because
at the same time I'm
building rapport,
I'm continuing to
have a conversation
and, you know, I can
do my review of systems
as I'm like doing
the exam head to toe.
And
And I find it especially
true if they're
like very young adolescents,
like 11, 12, 13,
14, where they're
still kind of kiddish.
And, you know, parents
often don't want
to leave the room.
They're still very
protective of their
kids at that point,
especially being
examined and you
touching them. And the
kid is very, can be
very frightened,
you know, being
examined alone for the
first time kind of.
with with an adult
right even though you're
the doctor so um so
i like to do it with
with the parents most
of the time sometimes
when they're like 16
70 18 and like parents
just can't wait to go
outside they're just
like they bring the
kid in like can i go
outside now i have
something to do i want to
make a few calls i'm
like all right see you
later all right uh i
always like to get a
few foot temperature
in the room are they
seem happy do the kids
seem to be getting
along are they giving
each other dirty looks?
Is the kid even
paying attention?
He or she's on
their phone,
things like that.
All right. And the
whole time we're
doing this, you're
trying to get a
sense of where in
the scheme are they?
Do they seem to
be fitting on the
early adolescence,
mid or late adolescence?
Because it's
going to, you can
tailor your talk
depending on that. And
of course, you know,
you're going to be
able to see, you
know, the pubertal
development as well.
all right um and at
some point you ask the
parents very simple i
say tell the students
keep it very simple
i would like to
talk to jane or john
alone for a bit would
you mind stepping out
of the room that's
all it takes most
parents are out the door
in two seconds they
know what's coming
right anyone that has
been with uh with me
over the years the
parents know that you
know every well check
visit and even sometimes
during just regular
visits for other
reasons i keep the
parents' room out, keep
the parents out of
the room for a minute
or for a few minutes.
And so they know what's
coming. They just
leave the room. No
problem, right? I count
only once or twice
thousands, thousands
of patients, teenagers
that, you know,
parents like not want
to go out of the room.
So keep it simple,
right? And so the first
picture is this is
a fake. This is fake
because parents are
never happy with the
kid. Teenagers are
never happy in general
to be there. They're
usually being forced
to be there. They have
better things to do
with their life than
spending the day at
the pediatrician's
office and being asked
personal questions,
being posed, prodded,
getting vaccines,
labs, and things
like that, okay?
Usually it's like
this. Parents telling
the pediatrician
everything they find
wrong with the teenager
and the teenager
is like giving
them this eye-eye.
All right? And again,
the younger the
patient is, the more
mindful you have
to be, especially
when they're very,
very young. So the
11, 12-year-olds,
be very, very mindful
of asking parents
to leave and talking
to the kid alone,
right?
Confidentiality,
very, very important,
okay? So the biggest
thing is that, you
know, you have
to tell them that
whatever we talk about
stays between us,
and I don't have to
tell your parents
anything. Simple as
that, okay? So that
includes anything
related to sexuality,
STDs, pregnancy, whether
they want contraception,
whether they're using
drugs or abusing
them, even mental
health, okay? The only
thing that can break
that confidentiality,
which is a mandatory
reporting for all
physicians, if there's
imminent danger. So it
has to be imminent
danger. Something is,
you know, you feel
that there's a danger
that is not just,
you know, possible,
but you really feel
as a physician that
something is going
on right now, okay?
And you have to tell
the tell the students
this. OK, this is
important because and
sometimes I'll I'll I'll
have to, you know, be
a little sensitive that
sometimes, you know,
even though you don't
tell them anything
and you don't say anything
about child having
***, things can we
can appear on reports
and billing statements.
So when we do STD
testing, a lot of times
they'll have itemized
bills of exactly what
we did, right? So a
lot of times I'll just
tell parents, hey, I
do usual stuff. It
doesn't mean your child
is having ***. I just
test everyone, okay? If
I feel like it might
cause some problems,
right? So you
can read it. It's
a busy slide you
can read out on
your own if
you're interested.
All right, so the
confidentiality
statement, I say
I just keep it
simple, just like
I said, right?
Kept confidential.
I'll tell your parents
anything you don't want
me to, right? Sometimes
we do. I do try to
get the teenagers to
talk to the parents and
me being a mediator.
And I say this, the
only exception is if
there's a danger to
yourself or someone
else. So there's that
danger clause, okay?
So that tells the
adolescent that,
you know, there
are limits to
confidentiality,
but it has to be.
It's going to be pretty
rare, okay? So you
never want to say, I'll
never say anything,
no matter what,
about anything, okay?
And really, the
main thing is threat
to others and
threat to self,
okay? So that means
STDs, pregnancies,
they can stay
confidential, okay?
All right, so the
biggest thing in the
interview process is
what we call the HEADS
assessment, all right?
And you do the HEADS
assessment alone.
We talked about
the confidentiality
statement already,
and the HEADS
assessment is just an
acronym. home education or
employment what activities
they're doing and
then drugs drinking
you know diet if it's
like um eating disorder
or something like that
or depression right
serious stuff ***
smoking suicide again
serious stuff and the whole
thing is that you start
with the softballs
the easier stuff
first building rapport
right before you get
into the to the harder
stuff right uh you never
you know if you just
met someone uh first
time you're seeing a
doctor and say hey how
are you doing i'm dr
chan hey jane how's it
going so uh you know
your parents are out
whatever we talk about
say so are you having
*** you know are you
depressed you know and
she's gonna be like uh
no no right so
again you have to
kind of build a
little trust first
before you you
know go into these
heavy-hitting
questions, right?
So that's the whole
point of the heads
assessment. So you're
asking about home, but
at the same time,
you're always looking
for red flags, okay?
So who lives at home?
You know, what's
going on at home? Do
you have chores? Do
you have a lot of
response? Some kids have
no responsibilities,
no chores. And other
kids, like, have
to take care of,
like, their eight
siblings, cooking,
cleaning. They have no time
for anything, and
they're just, like,
just overwhelmed
okay the living
situation right the
big thing is looking
for changes right so
are they moving new
school districts
things like that
okay divorce separations
you know maybe
you know mom or dad or
whoever they're living
with mainly maybe they
have a new partner
they've been divorced
for a while and
everything is you know
everything is fine that
you know dad has uh
has uh him or her every
other weekend but then
now all of a sudden
his new partner so um
you know you want to
you want to find out
about those things if
it's really relevant
or not okay um and of
course sometimes i
don't ask everyone this
question but you know
sometimes um um you
feel like you have to
escalate it right every
interview level there's
always escalations
or you feel like oh
i'm getting a a little
my spidey sense going
off and you ask about
whether they feel
safe at home right all
right education
employment what school you
go to what grade you're
in on your regular
class honors how you
do in school you can't
just say you do well
in school and they
always they always go
yes all right so you
have to kind of like get
a sense It's like A's,
B's, C's, and then
like B's, C's, and then
like you're passing
every class. Oh, no,
I failed three.
I was like, okay,
so the answer
is not you're
doing so great,
right? So it's
very relative.
So get specific.
What activities
they have?
How are their friends?
Any changes in
friends? Oh,
yeah, I don't
have any friends.
Or I used to
have a lot of
friends, but now
I have nobody.
So again, changes.
I always ask
about bullying
And again, do they
feel safe at school
And always employment,
right? As they get
older, a lot of kids
start working, right?
So especially 16,
17-year-olds They
can't wait to get a
job to make some money
So you always want to
ask about their work
What they're doing
Is it safe, right?
Some kids are just
working for their
parents And they're
like lifting concrete
blocks In a construction
zone, you know?
And they're like
15, 16 I don't
know how safe
that is, right?
And then you always
want to know about
their work schedule,
right? Some teenagers,
they're like so desperate
to make money or
they need to make
money for the families.
They're working
like almost full
-time jobs and they
have barely any
time for school,
right? So that
can be definitely
an issue, right?
All right, activities,
right? So we've
got home, education,
activities, HEA,
right? What do you
like to do in your free
time? What do you
enjoy? The sports,
right?
Going about it, right?
Don't ever forget
about asking about sleep,
right? Sleep doesn't,
it's not really an S
-like sack where it's
like danger, but you
really want to ask about
sleep because most
adolescents, even adults
in general are chronically
sleep deprived,
right? But especially
adolescents, why?
Because they want to
stay up late. They're
texting all night with
their friends. They're
watching YouTube and
Netflix. And do you
remember when high school
starts, right? High
school starts like seven
o'clock in the morning,
7.30, right? And
these kids, a lot of
them get up like one
and a half or two hours
before school to look
nice for high school.
Very, very common.
So they're not
getting not enough
sleep at all.
They fall asleep
at school.
They sleep all
afternoon, things like
that. So asking
about sleep hygiene,
especially cell phones
right next to them,
which they never want
to hear. Right. Right.
And the same time
you're getting this,
quote unquote, a
little benign history,
H-E-A, you're looking
for all these,
you know, warning
signs, you know, worse
than school performance,
weight changes,
attitude change,
personality changes,
social isolation,
right, things like that.
so trying to get a
sense uh for certain red
flags all right so now
you got that out of
the way you build the
rapport everything's
working out great you
guys are you know you
really feel like you
you're connecting and
they're opening up to
you and then you're
like all right now let's
let's get to the to
the real stuff okay
uh alcohol asking them
are they are they
drinking alcohol um again
asking specifics and
you can don't just if
you want to be like
get in and out of the
room so you can get
on to the next patient
yes if you ask do you
do drugs no you do you
drink alcohol no uh
are you depressed no do
you have *** no and
they'll they'll just
tell you what you want
to hear and then you
can be out of there
real quickly right but
are you really getting
a good history um most
of the time not right
so um kids they do
what a lot of us did
right they sneak a drink
here and there um they
go to parties things
like that all right
so uh you try to want
to get as much as you
can't either get um
and if they really say
no and you ask them
like all the you know
quick little follow-up
questions they're like
no no no i don't i
don't drink i don't
know i'm like okay yeah
great awesome uh and
then obviously about
drugs as well same thing
get specific if you
if you need to get
and again elevate the
conversation if you
need to elevate it right
um in terms of maybe
they're using *********
daily right uh and no
kid will ever admit
that they're addicted
to anything um and you
know this is um you
know one of those ways
you know instead of
saying the addiction
word you know do you
need it to help you feel
normal right or just
even like i don't know
how teenagers get the
money to get all this
stuff right so uh so
somebody's just you
know asking queries right
and they're different
uh if you get positive
answers you can
do a screening uh a
specific screening test
so you can look at it
on your own I don't
want to waste the time
during the lecture
reading out screens,
but, you know, these are
very common ones that
a lot of people use,
cage and craft, okay?
Cage is for alcohol
and craft is for
various things, okay?
All right, just
remember, remember what I
said about unintentional
injury and driving?
so you always want to
remind them you know
um drinking and driving
getting the car with
anyone that's under
the influence even if
you're not driving is
a mistake as well just
call your call your
parents or your guardian
call an uber uh even
if you get yelled at
in the in the end the
parents or guardian is
going to be very very
happy you you did
that okay um and it
doesn't have to be always
alcohol just being
impaired you know um
someone that's that's
high and driving is just
is bad right and kids
don't they don't think
like that they don't
think that uh if you're
high well i would
never drive drunk but
they'll drive you
know after smoking uh
********* and things
like that all right so
depression very very
common underdiagnosed a lot
kids are very good
at hiding it they'll
smile um they'll say
oh no i'm the happiest
person and so but you
still have to go through
um your your steps
okay uh and you'd be
surprised when you start
building rapport that
innocent looking teenager
who's smiling and
well groomed and just
answers questions
great they just like
break down uh when you
start asking these
questions because the truth
is you know they want
to tell you things
you just have to kind
of lay the land so it
makes it as easy as
possible you kind of
decrease the barriers for
them to open up because
they're holding it
all in just teenagers
They're just kids,
right? They want to tell
someone responsible and
they feel like they're
not safe enough to
tell their parents
sometimes. So hopefully
if you do it right,
you can lower those
barriers that they'll talk
to you, okay? So it's
not always obvious.
Start with the PSQ2.
Definitely an
11-year-old and
beyond, okay?
Definitely at 13.
11 and 12, again,
it's usually, for me,
it's a very quick screen.
I don't want
to scare them.
That they never want
to see me again and
dread going to the
doctor in the future.
And nor do I want
parents to get super,
you know, that
protective parental gene
to turn on and just
like, why do you want
to talk to my 11-year
-old? Like, he's just
playing video games.
He's just playing
video games and
like, you know, doing
Pokemon and reading
comic books. Like, what
are you going to talk
to him alone about?
Right. So, so you
want to, that's where
the art of medicine
comes in. Okay. And
if it's positive,
you go to the PHQ 9.
So PSQ-2 is very, very
quick and simple. I
love the PSQ-2. You
just asked about the
interest, right? You're
looking for anhedonia.
And whether they're
feeling depressed or
hopeless, very quick,
easy screen. And if
they say yes to
anything, you go on to
the PSQ-9, okay? So
you can read over it.
And it really does go
over something that
a lot of medical
students and residents
use is an acronym
called SIGICAPS, right?
When you talk about
the sleep disturbance,
the interest, again,
anhedonium, feelings of
guilt, it's very, very
important to ask that
because it's sometimes,
for no reason, they
feel very, very guilty
about the weirdest
things and you want to
ask them about that,
okay? the energy level
okay the concentration
appetite uh are they
uh you know uh very
very active like on
the go go go or they're
like no energy at all
okay uh and of course
suicidal ideation all
right again um when
you're talking about
suicide you're looking for
for um certain things
you know again more
red flags that make you
you know increase that
level of worry all
right or or you don't
find any red flags and
you're like all right
you know what they may
be a little depressed
but i don't think
they're they're suicidal
in any way or definitely
not imminently suicidal
okay so you're
looking for comorbid
conditions right so mental
illness family history
mental illness um um
basically you know
problems that that will
put them at more risk
Gender identity
can be an issue.
Them worrying about
the parents, how
they feel about
themselves and their
preferences can be
very, very stressful.
Other factors
such as bullying,
obviously incarceration,
destructive thoughts,
prior attempts to
suicide is a very, very
important question.
Have they ever tried to
commit suicide? right
uh uh whether they're
using substance giving
away all their
possessions access to
lethal means right so
sometimes you have to
ask you have access to
guns and things like
that uh you know
command hallucinations
somebody it's a weird
question somebody asks
like do you hear voices
you know are they
telling you anything okay
are you seeing things
okay uh this is a
big thing especially
you know for teenagers
remember i asked talked
about the home
education activities So
big changes or stressors
or inciting events,
you know, they can
react just like when
the people, you
know, a lot of, you
know, young people,
when did they attempt
suicide is like
when they break up,
right? Significant
breakups, you know,
my life is over. I'll
never find someone
as, as lovely as
that person again.
All right. Significant
changes or stressors,
right? Then you
look back five years
later, like, oh my
God, that was the best
thing to happen to me.
but during that time,
you know, they can't
think long-term,
okay? And again,
recent death
or suicide is
a risk factor.
All right, so
again, when you
have suicide
ideation, you want
to assess the
severity of it.
Did you have a
plan? Have they
made previous
attempts, okay?
You want to educate
them, especially
that, you know, it's
very normal, especially
growing up to have
these thoughts.
It's just that
at the level that
they're having
it, you know?
Everyone thinks
at some point what
life is going to be
like without them,
and maybe the
world's going to be
a better place
without them, right?
For most people,
they think about it,
but it's a fleeting
thought, okay?
And you want to
reassure them
that it's normal.
It doesn't mean
you're broken in
any way, okay?
It's just you want to
find their severity.
And, of course, at
every point, you always
want to counsel them
and have an action plan.
If these thoughts
progress, worsen, you're
really to the point
where you can't stop
thinking about these
things, or you you're
starting to plan how
you how it's going to go
on i need to know and
this is these are the
steps you need to take
okay and number one
easiest one is is is
having this hotline on
your phone knowing
the number and having
it ready okay so and
sometimes i'll even have
the the teenager like
program the number
into their phone so
they don't have to look
for it right when so
it's three o'clock in
the morning, and they're
having these crazy
thoughts, and something's
happened recently
that they want
to talk to them,
but I don't want
them, you know,
having trouble
finding the number,
right, I want
them to have, you
know, have it
ready access, okay,
again, you have to
ask these questions,
homicide ideation,
do they want to
kill someone, are
they very, very angry,
do they have a plan,
some kind of obsession
against this one
person, right, one time
I had a patient, just
had it out for the
teacher he's really
like uh just so angry
at at the teacher right
and uh you know we
had to escalate it a
little bit luckily it
turned out to be
nothing but uh but you
know it was it was uh
more than more than i
just don't like my
teacher okay uh again uh
if it's imminent danger
not just that they
have suicidal thoughts
or they don't like
the teacher it's
like imminent danger
that that uh you feel
as a clinician that this
is dangerous if they
go home and i don't
act on this and let
anyone know then you
can break confidentiality
okay all right uh
i always like if i
if i feel like like
i'm gonna be a man man
mandated reporter right
and i feel like i
have to break the
confidentiality i'll
try my best to have the
adolescent and talk
to the adolescent look
you know this is very
serious that are not
you know i think your
parents should be aware
um they you know they
have the best interest
you know i can mediate
and help you talk
to them about it and
you'd be surprised if
you if you do it right
do it well um you know
nine out of ten times
i can get a child to
agree to talk to the
parents and sometimes
you know i'll break
the news i'll be there
uh especially like
when you know you see a
teenager it was it's
pregnant uh they're only
like 15 16 yeah i
can't that's you don't
break confidentiality
for pregnancy right but
it would help this
teenage girl a lot if the
parents knew right
because you need services
she's gonna need you
know have get to the
ob-gyn doctor um you
know get the prenatal
vitamins you know someone
want to talk to it's
going to be very
stressful uh and a lot of
times you know you
kind of broker that uh
that communication
because you know the
teenager doesn't want to
uh is you know just shy
and you know feels
ashamed that they they
that this happened to
them and the parents
are angry mad and you
know you're you know you
know the provider
probably has the most
experience trying to
like calm everything down
all right always ask
about anxiety as well
okay it doesn't really
fit into heads doesn't
really fit into the
activity section the
a uh but you know with
depression comes anxiety
as well so a lot of
a lot of teenagers
have anxiety just imagine
you know us you know
every time we took a
test uh organic chemistry
test and if i didn't
test if i don't
get a i'm never gonna
get on medical school
right so um kids have
these thoughts too so
you want to ask them
about anxiety and another
screen is uh the gad
or generalized anxiety
disorder two or seven
okay right okay now
we get to the s smoking
all right asking
about tobacco products
luckily most kids don't
smoke anymore it's
cool to smoke there's
still some kids that
smoke but it's very very
rare compared to 20
years ago uh when i when
i started uh so uh
that's good right but
depending in demographics,
you know, some
people, you know, do
chewing tobacco, right, so
you want to ask, and
that's not healthy in
itself, all right,
but what kids do do,
especially in the middle
school kids, they do
vape, all right, so you
want to definitely ask
about it, all right,
and if they say yes,
definitely get details
about exactly whether,
how much, you know,
the whole thing you
you're taught, get details
about how much, how
often, things like
that, okay, and if no,
you know, My thing is,
you know, teenagers
lie all the time. I
can't control them lying
to me, but I can still
give them advice, right?
If they're lying, I
can still tell them
about the dangers,
about smoking, about
alcohol, about drugs,
about *** and STDs, okay?
So speaking of ***,
I should always
ask about the
gender identity
and the preference.
You know, kids are
very, very sharp and
aware about these
things. They're more
cool and hip and
understand about all
the variations than
adults, actually.
So these days,
very rarely, even
the males, they're
all macho. They
answer pretty easily
about it. So that's
very good. So you
don't need too much
of a qualifier.
But sometimes I do
if I feel like, oh,
they feel like I'm
singling them out
because of how they
look or how they're
dressing or anything
like that. I ask
everyone these same
questions, okay?
And again, asking
about ****** activity,
the number of partners,
you know, and do they
use protection? Have
they ever had a prior
STD? It's a good
question because
unfortunately, a lot of
teenagers have already
had STDs before, okay?
And the age-old
history gatherings,
like you never ask
a teenager, like,
are you ********
active? because they're
going to say no
because they think,
oh, well, I'm not
having *** right now.
And as us, we're
like, yeah, I know
you're not having
*** right now. You're
in the room in the
doctor's office.
But then, you know,
they're concrete
thinkers. Like,
have you ever had
*** before? You
know what *** is?
Have you ever had ***
at any time in your
life? And they're
like, oh, oh, yeah.
And they're like,
how many partners?
10, 12, whatever.
Okay.
So the biggest thing is
trying to quantify, like,
you know to me it's
it's it's different if
you know you're like
16 you've had one
you know one relationship
and you're having
*** and you're
monogamous and just one
person versus you're
16 and you're like you
can barely count uh
you run out of fingers
and toes uh from
the number of ******
partners you had all
right no matter what they
say you know could
be hard because i've
heard crazy stuff no
judgment right try not
try to keep a blank
face no matter what
you say like okay okay
In your mind, you're
like, oh my God, but
no judgment, okay?
They don't react
well to judgment,
all right? So again,
at every level,
if you suspect more
things, you have
to ask the questions
about it, okay?
All right, so you
got all the history.
You built some rapport
with the parents
and the kid. You talked
to the kid alone.
You went through
the whole head's
assessment, got a really
good sense of what's
going on, all
right? Like I said,
I'm going this reverse.
First, I probably
have done the
physical exam already.
But sometimes you do
definitely go back,
depending on what they
told you, into a little
bit more in depth,
right? Because sometimes
they'll tell you,
oh, yeah, by the way,
when you're talking
to them along, I do
have headaches. I didn't
say it in front of
parents because I worry
them or I get stomach
aches and things like
that. So you'd be
surprised. As you get
them talking, they
start telling you more
stuff, right? So you
always want to pay
attention to the vitals,
right? Do they have
high blood pressure,
you know,
heart rate's high,
whatever it is. are they
vitals or vitals okay
the general assessment
you're making a note
of their mood their
attention their hygiene
are they well-groomed
are they dirty and
slovenly they smell you
know a lot of teenagers
their hygiene can
be a little questionable
sometimes uh their
clothes immaculate
or it's like torn and
dirty you know um so
um my thing is you're
making these assessments
in your head and you're
making judgments but
you know you're not
going to write down
everything on the when
you document okay so
most times when you
document it's going to
be alert active no acute
distress answering
questions cooperatively
uh and coherently things
like that okay the
skin what what problems
happen in teenagers
right acne big one
okay so um a lot of
times they don't tell
you these uh these things
or they don't want
to complain about it
and then but we do know
adolescents just like
us in our whole life
where you know everyone
is a little vain
and adolescents are
especially vain because
they're making these
they're going to do these
changes into adulthood
they want to look
as good as possible
most of the time right
so acne something that
we can help with right
there are medications
for acne if needed
uh so you want to ask
them about it if you
see it it can't those
nigricans that darkness
uh behind the back of
the neck any sign of
insulin resistance or
endocrine problems
okay moles cutting very
very common uh in uh
teenagers okay maybe
you see signs of *****
bruising okay uh they
look really pale
right teenage females
menstruating the menstruation
right all over the
place their diet is
very very poor you know
we just recently had
a teenage girl who
had like um and was like
a hemoglobin five or
six it's like super
super low right from
from just uh you know a
heavy bleeding uh over
months and months okay
and she's she's felt
just a little dizzy
you know uh tattoos
tattoos are so common
it's that you know again
don't judge anything
from people having
tattoos at all at all
uh you know just the
one thing is that i like
to ask him like what
is the what do these
tattoos mean uh and
you know that that's
another way about see
building rapport because
most people are putting
something on their
skin for a reason so
um so that's a good
question iceberg and they
like talking about it
uh most of the time
that's why they put
it out for someone to
see so uh you can give
you a little insight
and again another thing
to talk about build
rapport okay piercings
and piercing again
no judgment zone some
people like to pierce.
Again, if it's
permanently disfiguring,
that's not a great thing.
They're getting
infected, you know,
they're piercing
cartilage, maybe,
or it's too
many, and you're
actually worried
about, you know,
disfigurement and or
getting affected. And
definitely, if you're,
some people, especially
a black population
are prone to keloid
formation, you should
warn them about that
right so uh and then a
lot of times they know
they know about this
and oh yeah i had one
and i had to get it
removed and things
like that and many times
they don't bring it
up to you but you
you're looking at the
piercing like oh does
that hurt it's like the
earlobe is all red and
things like that okay
right again uh looking
at the head and neck
uh checking the hair
hair loss texture i
can go along with
certain conditions with
thyroid that can occur
in uh in teenagers uh
thyroid problems uh
eating disorders right
again eyes red or pale
maybe they're smoking
too much ********* uh
their eyes are injected
uh the pale because
they're anemic right
ear impaction uh nose
bleeding uh you know
the mouth the neck
look check the lymph
nodes. Remember, you
have the, one of the top
causes is malignancy,
right? So lymph nodes
can swell up, right?
Lymphoma, leukemia,
okay? Again, the
acanthosis, and
again, I didn't write
it in like checking
their thyroid,
right? A lot of
times when the
thyroid problems start
appearing is when
they're teenagers,
okay?
Heart, lungs, abdomen,
want to just make a
note, gynecomastia
in males is very,
very common.
They're very sensitive
about it. You can
just reassure them.
Sometimes all you
need is maybe some
weight loss and sometimes
it's you know just
reassurance that
over time it won't
be as prominent um so
but it's something you
should address okay
uh and again you're
still doing an exam
but you're looking
for specific things
maybe like scars it's
like hey how did you
get that oh that
was a knife fight oh
okay okay you want
to tell me about that
all right um extremities
again that cutting
it could be very
very subtle all right
i think i have a picture
of cutting somewhere
um uh they a lot
of times they forms
but a lot of these
teenagers they're very
savvy right they
realize oh if you cut in
my forehead people
can start seeing it
so they cut their thighs
right so very very
common and it could
be very very subtle
and it just looks
like just linear like
just linear marks
doesn't look like someone
actually cut their skin
okay other scars in
the back right teenagers
you really want
to assess for scoliosis
very very important
okay um again neuro
exam which you should
be doing in general
okay so assessing for
scoliosis if you do
see there's in say
asymmetry we have this
little plastic thing
called a scoliometer,
right, that you can put
on and see, you know,
you can see where,
what degree it is.
And if it's more than
seven degrees, then
you should work them
up, right? Either
send an orthopedics
doctor or get an
actual x-ray scoliosis
series of x-rays to
actually measure the
angle, what they call
the cob angle, okay?
And the reason why
scoliosis is especially
important to
teenagers is because
they're going to go
through that growth
spurt. So the scoliosis
is usually pretty,
pretty stable until
they start going
through the growth
spurt. And the body is
already having trouble
keeping things in
balance. And when
you go through the
growth spurt, they
have even more trouble,
okay?
Peer world development,
obviously, they're
going through puberty.
You always want to
ask for a chaperone,
okay? So, you know,
it's definitely, you
need a chaperone, okay?
You cannot, parents
are not chaperones,
right? I always
say, if parents say
something or they feel
that you did something
inappropriate, now
you have patient and
the parent saying
it. So you have two
against one. That's
even worse. You have to
have someone not
necessarily on your
side, but someone who's
like more neutral,
a medical assistant,
a nurse, okay?
Someone, okay? I always
say medical students
are not my chaperone.
So I usually,
even the medical student
I'm working with, I
still get a medical
assistant to be in
the room when I'm
checking the puberty
development, okay? You
should always understand,
you know, the stages
of puberty, okay?
It starts from 8
to 13 years of age.
Males, like, usually
a year later. But you
can see, just like we
remember, I always say,
remember when you
were in middle school,
the females were
much taller and more
developed than the
boys, right? The
girls started looking
like women and the
boys still looked
like boys, right?
It was pretty apparent.
When they were
in high school,
things started
catching up.
And by the middle, mid
or late high school,
the girl who was
towering over the boy
is now looking up to
that young man, okay?
So if you remember that,
you kind of remember,
obviously, girls
start earlier, okay?
So the growth spurt,
it's also important
to know that the
growth spurt in girls
happens early, right?
Just like I said,
they feel much taller
when they were middle
school and the boys
were small. And the
boys, as they went
through puberty later,
their growth spurt
happens later, okay?
This is just tender
staging, good
look over it.
Basically, you should
know that tender
stage one means they're
pre-puberal, okay?
Kids,
all right?
First stage in a
female is the breast
budding. And the first
stage, the male is not.
The hair is, all of a
sudden, the *********
are larger, right?
So one day, boy's
showering, and he
looks at him like, huh?
What's that, you
know? And so that's
the first sign
of puberty, okay?
And so that's
important because once
you see that they're
starting puberty,
you have to, you know,
as a pediatrician,
give them talk about
what to expect,
right? And parents
really would
appreciate that
talk because they
don't want to talk
about it, okay?
plans what do you want
to discuss whatever
vaccines they need
the typical teenage
vaccines or the hpv
human papillomavirus
vaccines you guys all
had it um uh all these
vaccines before
getting to college and
everything okay tdap
um meningococcal
vaccines mcv4 and
meningitis b is can be
optional so that's not
required for school but
these two are required
for school Okay.
Depending on what you
assessed, did you,
do you want to check
for anemia? Did
you feel like they
have a polycystic
ovarian syndrome,
menstrual issues,
obesity, STD testing?
So again, whatever,
depending on their
age, what you found
out as a problem,
you order lab
work. Do they need
referrals for anything?
Any medications
you want to start?
Are they depressed?
Maybe I see a
psychiatrist or
psychologist? Do you
want to sit on
antidepressants, okay?
Any imaging, right?
A lot of kids have
headaches. Do you
need to get an MRI
or a CAT scan,
right? And of course,
anticipatory guidance,
you always want
to give them,
okay? And whatever,
words of wisdom for
both the parents
and the patients,
and of course, any
follow-ups if needed,
okay? So a normal
plan in general
is comprehensive,
right?
Just a word on mental
health care. The primary
care is usually your
primary provider for
mental health care,
right? There's just not
enough mental health
services for all the
patients that need it.
So a lot of times as
a provider, you're
doing the screening, and
a lot of times you have
to start the medications
if you feel it's
needed, because it
may be months before
they go get to see a
psychiatrist that can
prescribe them, and you
don't want them suffering
with depression and
suicidal ideation or
whatever it is, or
anxiety disorder when
you can, you can help
them okay and again all
these other people that
you can refer to if
needed okay remember
we started to finish
the circle about early
early and late amid
and late adolescence so
again depending on
what you find out about
where they fit um you
know you want to have
a discussion uh so um
a lot of times you feel
that the struggles
that things they're
talking about in middle
school it's like seems
so trivial but you
know you don't want to
dismiss their struggles
because the parents
are probably, oh, that's
so silly, you know.
But to a middle
school kid,
it's really
important, right?
You want to talk
about the puberty.
If you're going to
talk about things, just
talk in really concrete
terms, terms they
can understand, right?
So no analogies with
their early adolescence,
okay? And again,
safety is very, very
important, right?
Because, again, unintentional
injuries, right?
Or they're most likely
to do things without
acting, right? That
prefrontal cortex is
extremely immature at
that point. That's what's
going to stop you and
make you think before
you act. And the younger
you are, the less
likely you are for that
to be working well.
And you want to, again,
plant those seeds
of health and
precaution, and hopefully
they're listening. I
usually always have to
think idealistically
that they are listening.
They may pretend
that they don't hear
anything But I do
think they're listening
Again,
middle school They're
still concrete But
you can have a higher
level of discussion
Talk about
relationships, family,
love Again, this is
when they're driving
So always have that
really strong talk about
driving Driving, no
drinking, driving, things
like that And, you
know, things to promote
independence, right?
They're probably going
to look for a job So
you can give them a
little job counseling,
right? Again, you're
planting more seeds.
You're going to reinforce
the seeds that you
told them over the last
three years that you've
been seeing them.
And then, you
know, hopefully,
again, hopefully they're
listening, right?
And when they're older,
this is when, you
know, as a pediatrician,
you feel very
rewarded. You get them
to this late adolescence.
They're kind of
starting to figure out.
They're getting kind
of over the worst part,
right? Having more
mature conversations,
goal-oriented.
This is what I
want to do with
my life, right?
You don't have to
lecture them so much It's
more like just talking
Almost like a friend
or colleague And just
giving them a little
more guidance Oh, so you
want to be a mechanic
Okay, great And then
talk to them about
these things And again,
continue to reinforce
those points But hey,
still, no drinking and
driving I know you're
older More parties,
more drugs, more ***
Just be careful, okay?
You can't let
up. You're still
young. You have a
whole future ahead
of you, things
like that, okay?
All right.
And then the
transition to care.
Again, like I said,
every pediatrician kind
of lets go of the
patients at different
times. Sometimes the
patients are ready.
Sometimes they can't
wait. I've had some 18,
19 years, like, they
run off to the adult
doctor, right? Which
is fine, right? Right.
My thing is always
if you the child, you
know, 821 and above
starts developing adult
medical problems, I have
high blood pressure,
a kidney failure for
whatever reason, you
know, high cholesterol,
things like that.
Yeah. Maybe it's time
to go to an adult
or family medicine
doctor. A lot of us
pediatricians, these
adolescents that have
truly a lot of
pediatric problems,
maybe like cystic
fibrosis, Down syndrome,
Prader-Willi, a lot
of times we keep them
because we are very
comfortable with these
conditions because
it's like a pediatric
thing. And a lot of
adult doctors just really
aren't as comfortable.
So a lot of times
we'll just keep them
for as long as we can.
And until they start
really developing
adult medical
problems, okay? So
it can be a gray
zone, all right?
But the biggest
thing is that when
they do move on to
someone else, you
want to transition
them properly.
Give them a name of
a trusted doctor.
Make sure that
doctor has their
records. Maybe
even talk to
that physician
if they need to
because it improves their
outcomes overall, okay?
How do you document?
you should really
document uh the history
is going to be a little
bit more complex and
you really do sometimes
have to say the history
that you get from
the parents and the
what the parents said
and then i almost always
would write a note
like patient discussed
alone and these are
the things we discuss
about *** drugs rock
and roll blah blah blah
blah okay and uh and
that and i always write
on the physical if
there's a chaperone
present and who it was
okay all right here's
the summary slide um
you can read it on it
on your own it should
all make sense uh if
you're listening and
um really that's it
all right this is my my
my mentality when i'm
seeing a teenager is
always you're trying to
give them the building
blocks plant a seed
and hopefully as
they're progressing uh
during this very very
difficult time that
they'll grow up into you
know productive young
adults like most of
you are now listening to
this lecture all right
help guide them through
their very difficult
time and here's the
lecture feedback
form once again some
references and i put a
little supplement few
supplementary slides if
you want to read about
it on the arkansas
adolescence right to
care and the new york
one uh very very similar
and you'll see it's
basically what we
talked about right
but if you're
interested to read
over the particulars
You can okay